[Musik]
tief in lappland nahe der stadt
rovaniemi liegt das weihnachtsmann dorf
der ort an dem der weihnachtsmann wohnt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aus der ganzen welt kommen die besucher
in den hohen norden
seit 1985 empfängt der weihnachtsmann
hier nämlich jedes jahr tausende
weihnachtsfans direkt in seinem
wohnzimmer und hört sich all ihre
wünsche an
hallo ich bin der weihnachtsmann und ich
fühle mich ziemlich echt
wir sind hier am polarkreis der das tor
zum norden ist aber auch der eingang zur
welt der märchen und träume ein
wundervoller ort um sich etwas zu
wünschen
zweifel an der existenz des
weihnachtsmanns gibt es hier nicht man
ist niemals zu alt um an den
weihnachtsmann zu glauben seit meiner
kindheit weiß ich dass der
weihnachtsmann geschenke bringt ich
wollte mal sehen ob es ihnen wirklich
gibt der weihnachtsmann spricht sogar
portugiesisch ja ich glaube er ist
mehrsprachig oder so
nicht jeder kann persönlich beim
weihnachtsmann vorbei schauen
deswegen kommen jedes jahr rund 500.000
briefe wunschzettel und karten in seinen
offiziellen postamt an die ganze post
kann der weihnachtsmann natürlich nicht
allein erledigen
fleißige elfen greifen ihn dabei unter
die arme
[Musik]
wir haben jeden tag geöffnet das ganze
jahr lang das hier ist ein normales
finnisches postamt man kann karten oder
päckchen verschicken oder schöne
briefmarken kaufen und natürlich kommen
hier auch alle briefe an den
weihnachtsmann an gern schicken die
besucher auch von mir aus karten mit
nord polarkreis stempel nach hause an
ihre lieben der weihnachtsmann weiß
jeden der an ihn adressierten briefe zu
schützen
aber manche post geht ihm besonders nah
[Musik]
manchmal bekomme ich briefe in denen mir
kleine mädchen oder jungs schreiben das
sie selbst alles haben aber etwas für
eine andere person erbitten weil die
person hilfe braucht diese briefe sind
mir besonders lieb
[Musik]
ein ganzer themenpark rund um
weihnachten im dorf des weihnachtsmannes
kann man alles was zwar wenn es zeit
gehört an einem tag erleben
seit 30 jahren ist das dorf bei
rovaniemi die pilgerstätte für
weihnachtsfans der legende nach liegt
die wahre heimat des geschenkebringer es
aber noch viel höher im norden
uns wurde immer erzählt dass der
weihnachtsmann vom comfort und uri kommt
das ist ein berg der wie ein ohr gewohnt
ist so dass der weihnachtsmann die
wünsche der kinder aus aller welt hören
kann
sehr abgelegen nahe der finnisch
russischen grenze deshalb wurde das
weihnachtsmann dorf hierher gebaut um es
reisenden leichter zu machen den
weihnachtsmann zu treffen
das santa claus village ist zwar das
ganze jahr über geöffnet im winter aber
besonders stimmungsvoll bis zu minus 20
grad celsius kalt wird es hier perfekt
um ein paar runden mit dem
hundeschlitten zu drehen mit den
rentieren geht es deutlich langsamer wie
schaffte es der weihnachtsmann überhaupt
so viele kinder gleichzeitig zu
beschenken
zeit ist relativ
und das ist es auch schon man muss
einfach wissen wie man ein millionen
orten gleichzeitig sein kann
nach jahrhundertelanger übung schaffe
ich das ziemlich gut
abends wird es im weihnachtsmann dorf
richtig gemütlich lagerfeuer oder musik
shows hier liegt auch der letzte
weihnachtsmuffel den zauber des festes
[Musik]
und alle die nicht besuchen können lässt
der weihnachtsmann schön grüßen
[Musik]
ich wünsche euch allen frohe weihnachten